so imagine you got this great business
idea to compete with netflix hulu amazon
and you go pitch the idea to nbc
universal
you go to walt disney you go to time
warner warner brothers jp morgan chase
goldman sachs alibaba mbc universal
and at the end of every single meeting
these guys say yes we're in and you
don't raise a hundred million dollars
not a half a billion dollars
not a billion dollars you raise 1.8
billion dollars and you
launch this company april 6 2020
at a time where disney is having
record-breaking subscribership disney
plus
where you see netflix tiger king blowing
up 34 million people watching the first
10 days
you end up seeing all these guys getting
the subscriber records
and six months after you raised 1.8
billion dollars
you shut down you know what that
company's name is quibby
wall street journal comes out two days
ago saying quibby
is shutting down barely after starting
six months can you imagine this now
let's unpack
this quippy business model let's see
what they are so could be
a couple different things you need to
know about kubi number one their whole
idea was we're going to make 10 minute
videos right so
10 minute short films and we're going to
compete because nowadays
you know the younger audience wants to
watch movies on their phone
they don't really want to go out and
watch it on tv they're going to watch it
on their phone so let's make sure 10
minute clips
let's go get the biggest a-listers right
i'm talking any one of them you name
them they got them by the way i got the
list i'll show it to you
all the big a-listers let's pay them a
hundred thousand dollars
per minute is what we're gonna pay them
and let's go compete with everybody else
right so now the leadership team of
quibby
when they came out quick bites big
stories
the guy holding the cameras mario and
mario are you not a fan of quibby i am
he's a fan of quibby so he's heartbroken
he was crying a little bit earlier
so meg whitman and
jeffrey katzenberg are the ones who go
out there and lead quibby now meg
whitman's resume she took
ebay from 8 million to 32
billion she even ran for governor in
2010 of california as a republican
she's worth 5.1 billion dollars 64 years
old fyi do you know what her favorite
shows to watch on tv
history channel which the average age of
history channel
is 50 plus the audience they were
targeting was
18 to 24 18 to 30. they wanted the
younger audience to consume their
content
jeffrey katzenberg on the other side
here's a man
with a ridiculous you know resume that
he has we're talking about
you know the little mermaid beauty and
the beast you know the lion king
aladdin can you imagine working on these
big hits and he's worth
900 a million 900 million dollars
founder of quibby
69 years old they together come up and
start this idea called quibby
i told you they raised 1.8 billion
dollars you can go to crunch base and
see who the people are
alibaba you got the warner walt disney
warner brothers you put sony i missed
sony you
they pretty much got everybody right now
when they started the company
they came out saying we're gonna give a
hundred thousand dollars per minute so
when they said a hundred thousand
dollars per minute whose attention did
they get
i'm gonna go through this list fairly
quickly but try to you know
hang in there with me when i'm going
through the list you're gonna know these
names
chrissy taygan you know the name uh
titus burgess let me continue here
chance the rapper who did punk which was
the old show i think ashland kutcher
used to do back in the days
j.lo christen bell yara shaditi tracy
morgan
carly claus nick jonas gabriel iglesias
ridiculous lineup right there
demi lovato let me continue here andy
sandberg
liam hemsworth christopher waltz sophie
turner corey hawkins
rhys witherspoon kiki palmer joel kim
booster
queen latifah i mean again they got the
rock they got kevin hart they got
john travolta eva longoria andy garcia
if i go on trevor noah you know a lot of
these names tyra banks joe
jones usher you know what these names
these are big names that they got they
got all lebron james
they got all the big names and they
still failed why did they fail
why are they shutting down six months
later well they also came up
with a 60-minute version in
quibby for six minutes so 60 minutes did
a six minute version on quibby
yet they're targeting an audience of 18
to 34 years old but they want to do 60
minutes on
six minutes and say wait a minute the
average viewer of 60 minutes you know
how old it is
60 years old and all of these actors may
be rock stars but 18 to 34.
huh let's continue so what happens with
coiby recently when they shut down this
is what katzenberg
and meg whitman said two days ago
quibby is not succeeding okay likely for
one of two reasons because of the idea
itself wasn't strong enough to justify
uh state alone streaming a service or
because of our timing so what they're
talking about the fact that
you know maybe the idea wasn't good or
pandemic kind of hit and
you know people were really really
consuming of videos on their phones
because
they were at home so they weren't
working they were watching stuff on
their tv or their pc but
i can tell you for myself i'm 42 years
old when the pandemic came and i was 41
i consume more content on my phone than
this matter of fact let's look at some
data on what happened during this time
so during the pandemic this is an
article from august 5th so it's not a
another a today article but this is from
two months ago
tv watching and online streaming search
during lockdown
ready adults spend nearly six and a half
hours a day watching tv and online
videos
one hour and 11 minutes per day spent
watching streaming videos
double what it was before the pandemic
12 million customers signed up to new
services like netflix
amazon prime and disney viewing figures
for video streaming services
up 71 watch this quibby got 5.6 million
subscribers
in the first when they first got started
their app was ranked number three the
day they launched april 6 their app was
ranked number three
immediately they were not even in the
top 50. and reports says quibby lost
92 percent of its original
early users after free trials meaning
when they first came out
they got 910 000 users because they gave
it away for free for a couple weeks
only 72 000 agreed to pay afterwards
think about this what is taking place
with them so now
q2 was a tipping point in streaming wars
here's how the media giant stacked up if
you look at some data here
disney hit 60 million
plus on disney plus 60 million on track
to crack their number they were just
crushing it
netflix was crushing it every data you
pretty much look at
was a great great time for these guys
now let's continue a little bit more
with quibby
while they came out rather than spending
a chunk of their 1.8 billion dollars
advertising on tick tock or
you know instagram 18 to 34 maybe not
facebook but even facebook because
facebook allows you to go viral
or or twitter here's what they ended up
spending their money they spend money
advertising
on oscars okay they spend money
super bowl they advertise during the
super bowl
do you know what happened when they
advertise on super bowl let me read this
article to you that i think is very
important for you to see
when they advertised on uh
uh what do you call it on um uh on
a super bowl do you know what the
average viewer thought they were
watching
watch this okay quibby super bowl
add okay you ready watch what it says
here could be super bowl ads 70
you got to see this this is just classic
hilarious
when they came out with their ad here it
is
when they came out with the ads here's
the article in the market research shows
it's oscars and super bowl at 70
of respondents said they thought quibby
was a food delivery service
how bad of a job can you do on
advertising where i'm watching you spend
five and a half million dollars on
super bowl ads you could have spent that
five and a half million dollars of ads
on tick tock twitter instagram
to get the 18 to 34. so let's look at
what kind of followership they got
on tick tock they had 512 000 followers
on tick tock 13.4 million likes which is
not bad that's the audience you want to
be on
facebook they only had 50 000 likes
which by the way it doesn't take a lot
to get a lot of followers on facebook
you could have spent
a million dollars and you would have
blown up your facebook and got things to
go viral for people to spend money
twitter they only had 57 000 followers
instagram they only had 281 000
followers
so they weren't really spending a lot of
money there but they did spend money on
oscars and by the way the quirby
executive denies that this happened
meaning that people thought
quibby was a food delivering service so
they could completely
miss the marks now watch what happens
here
blake robbins comes out and tweets and
he says
put david dobrik's vlogs exclusively on
quibby on actual release schedule also
give mr beast which i don't know if you
know who mr b says obviously use the
wrong name here but use mr beats a
massive budget
and watch him create magic because the
question was asked
how would you fix quibby that's what
blake robin said
reed the manager of mr beast comes out
and said
we tried they said what no you ready
this is mr b's 45 million
subscribers he is exactly the audience
that could be wants
i just sorted by their most popular
views his number one video has 101
million views then 76 76 75 74 70. so he
didn't get lucky
73 72 72 68 this guy
is crushing it they could have got a guy
like this but no they're not interested
they want more
older stars who are a-listers to pay
more money they don't want to get a guy
like this because who would follow
someone
like this i mean honestly who would ever
watch somebody like mr b
not a lot of people maybe only 45.3
million subscribers which by the way if
you combine nbc abc cnn fox
you know cbs if you combine all of those
youtube channels combined he's got more
subscribers than them
combined you can add espn on top of that
bloomberg on top of that he's still got
more than they do he's got the eyeballs
so now here's an example borat just
comes out right now if you're watching
borah at marketing board at a genius and
they're supposed to be marketing
geniuses meg whitman is a genius she
didn't get lucky taking ebay from 8
million to 32 billion
here's what david delbrick did
team it up with borat to promote the new
movie now watch this here's the 8.1
million subscriber channel i don't even
think this is the main channel but it's
one of his channels
watch what happens this video comes out
two days ago here's what the video looks
like watch this i'm gonna bring you guys
here today to introduce you guys
to one of my friends he flew in all the
way from kazakhstan
watch this
here's how you do marketing watch what
he does there's 150 000 tesla there
watch
oh my god oh my god back it up back it
up
back it up back it up backs it up
[ __ ] okay you ready
[Music]
i will get this six point five four
eight four million viewers in two days
that's how you do advertising okay
you get these young guys know what
they're doing if you would have gotten
these younger people they know what they
do to promote quibby
can you imagine what mr beast would have
done if he would have been on quibby
and they would have said can you make a
video 76 million views imagine the
amount of eyeballs said i want to go
watch a unique series
with mr beast now a couple of names they
could have gone if you go do some
research on who the big youtubers i made
the list over here for myself
okay you ready logan and jake paul
whether you like them or not that's your
audience
you got we talked about it ninja emma
chamberlain
pewdiepie ryan you know ryan the kid
that's got 22 million subscribers make
seven million a year
you got maybe even pewdiepie is a little
bit older but he'll still be good liza
koshy dolan brothers tal fishman
merrell twins tessa brooks uh charlie
the amelio 20
videos she's got on youtube you ready
she's got 20 videos on youtube you know
how many subscribers she's got
nearly eight and a half million
subscribers you think you want that
audience
that's the audience that can mark it for
you so then one of the things they did
the mistakes that they made let's unpack
this
when you're watching a video on uh
quibby
you couldn't take screenshots they turn
up their technology was so ridiculous
where you would watch you turn it around
you start watching a movie right here
right 10 minutes ridiculous technology
very smooth
very very swift but you couldn't take
screenshots because they didn't want
their content to be stolen the audience
they want wants screenshots to take a
screenshot and send to a friend and say
watch this over here watch this over
here watch this over here they couldn't
get their users to advertise and work
for them
they prevented that from happening so
imagine you get a new app that comes out
with a bunch of regulations that you
can't use do you like that
doesn't it need to be a little bit freer
my good friend robert kiyosaki wrote a
book once
called rich dad poor dad the book ends
up selling i think 32 million copies
that's up here
you know what he said one time he says
pat you know the book's been sold 80
million times 80 million copies have
been sold
32 million of which he got paid on give
or take
he said i asked him a question i said
how do you feel about the fact that the
book's being pirated you know what he
said
he says i don't care if it's pirated you
know why i said why it's free
advertising for me
it's more advertising quibby missed the
big
mark on basic advertising lets your
users work for you
but they didn't do that so what ends up
happening they got another lawsuit right
now that's going on which could be one
of the reasons why they're shutting down
because
uh the company is banning a lawsuit by
interactive company called echo which
claims quibby is violating its patents
and have stolen trade secrets
the fight centers on a key feature of
quebec that plays different videos for
users depending on whether they are
holding their phone horizontally or
vertically by the way they had a meeting
with the quibby team and i think
katzenberg was in a meeting when they
presented the technology
and then they went and used the
technology under whether they used them
or not that's what's being claimed right
now
and echo is backed up by a lot of strong
big players so when big players sue you
you better be ready
because they're not just winging and
saying here's a lawsuit for you when you
get sued by big names
you better respect that paper's coming
to you so they're suing them so i don't
know what's going to happen right there
now a couple of things to be thinking
about while we're going through this
what mistakes number one
know your customer and not only know
your customer know where your customer
is
so if you know who your customers are
going to say 18 to 34 great
where is your customer maybe insta maybe
you know tick tock maybe i gotta go get
some of these big youtubers if that's
the audience you want go get them why
are you getting bigger a-listers that
you have to pay
more money for just because they have a
bigger name during their late 40s
mid-40s some of them you've got to wear
in their 30s but go get some of these
younger guys they missed the mark on
that part right there the whole thing
with marketing was a big mark
the other thing we can learn from this
just because you have money just because
you have big names
doesn't mean that they're hungry you
know the whole idea about a startup guy
that comes up and says we're going to go
out there and take over the world
that hunger goes away the richer you
become for most people
who are not visionaries for example elon
musk is not doing it to go out there and
become rich and all this other stuff
elon musk cannot help himself jobs
cannot help himself when he
don't want to create a pixar he had a
chip on his shoulder he wanted to prove
a point
you fired me apple watch what i'm gonna
do there wasn't that
element with quibby this is kind of like
a business you know what it didn't work
did you see the statement
wasn't succeeding maybe because of the
idea maybe because of timing
but it's not succeeding so guess what
we're just closing it down
by two beasts katzenberg and whitman
these are not regular lightweight people
but they shut it down the other part of
it is uh you're not
connecting with your target audience are
you a tech company or your media company
because
i don't know if you know or not even
though they have all this great content
they didn't own most of it the content
wasn't theirs
the content wasn't owned by them so are
you just the software that does this
because if you're just a technology
company that's a different story
versus netflix goes out and says we're
going to buy this content we're going to
pay for we're going to own the content
quibby didn't own most of their content
and money alone won't do it
they didn't listen to their audience
fast enough when you're coming up and
you have an mvp product audience is
going to tell you we don't like this we
don't like that we don't like this you
got to be
faster to make the changes we just
launched an app three weeks ago two
weeks ago
and from day one one night we stayed
here had four zooms and people were
calling on midnight till one o'clock in
the morning we're staying i'm here with
all my staff members
we're answering questions because you
got to listen to your users if you don't
listen to your users
quickly you lose them especially if you
say your target audience is young
and last but not least a couple things
why did they quit
why are you shutting down how do you
know this is not going to work out why
are you closing up shop
how do you know it's not gonna work out
you realize netflix nothing major
happened to netflix
until netflix came out with oranges the
new black and netflix came out with the
house of cards
nothing happened to netflix until they
came out with that the moment they came
out with that i remember i got
calls text messages people telling me
watch house of cards watch house of
cards watch house of cards
i'm about to go to tuscany italy i come
home i watch all the 12 episodes
throughout the night i couldn't go to
sleep
i said i'm going to sleep on the flight
to tuscany italy just because my dad
a guy named carl all my friends you got
to watch us so then babe i guess we need
netflix and we've had netflix since then
so they gave up maybe a little too early
where they could add a little bit more
momentum
six months of giving up and they're
gonna give 350 million dollars back to
the investors and they're just gonna
move on
i don't understand that concept maybe
the lawsuit is bigger than we know
i don't know but six months is too quick
amazon needed transparent before they
took off
who don't need the hands made tail even
disney had the mandalorian isn't that
the star wars series that you like they
came out with and
boom next thing you know it takes off
you know at this point of the game
a part of it for me was exciting because
you saw
goldman alibaba you're like oh my gosh
this could compete it's
capitalism is great when you got a lot
of different ideas competing against
each other
but the other part of it is if you let's
just say the lawsuit's not the big issue
let's just say the loss is not the big
issue let's say it's not
let's say you decide to completely
change the strategy before you throw in
the towel
and you say let's go get these big
youtubers and why don't we give them a
different perspective then give them the
money what's that
don't give them money give them equity
what do you mean give them equity say
here's
here's 10 million shares that we want to
go find talent hey mr beast you want
some shares
let's go build this thing to 100 billion
dollar company hey you know
logan and jake you guys want let's give
you some shares so give them ownership
where they sell it not a hundred
thousand dollar per minute type of stuff
and see what these young bucks could do
i mean obviously mr beast has got 45
million subscribers because he knows
what he's doing
why throw in the towel that part i fully
don't understand after six months
especially when you still have 350
million dollars i do understand you need
more money to go create more content
but maybe your strategy needs a massive
change netflix used to send those dvds
do you remember you would buy they would
send you
and they would not send another one
until you send it back to them and i was
assisting even my wife used to do that
all the time with netflix
four movies came in send them back
another four movies came in send them
back
and then netflix adjusted and one two
completely different approach not 150
billion dollar company
just because this didn't work at first
doesn't mean you throw in the
damn towel quibby so unless if there's
something
darker bigger that we don't know about
i think they shouldn't have given up and
i think they should have gone at least
for six more months 12 more months
test this one more thing out and see
what would have happened
with these big youtubers and then from
there if it failed
you don't lose a lot of money you give
up equity you didn't give up money you
gave up equity
let them also go fight for it anyways i
don't know that's my thoughts what do
you think about what happened to these
guys
and if you're watching this video saying
pat you know i enjoyed the way you broke
down this whole quippy concept
i got another video i want you to watch
it's a whole concept about disneyland
and disney world
what happened to disneyland both disney
owned company
both ran by bob chapin and uh if i'm
saying the name correctly and uh
bob iger and executive chairman and ceo
one is in la one is in anaheim one is in
uh florida one is in california
california one still isn't open for
toronto plus the florida wasn't open
july 11th what's the difference if you
haven't seen that video
i highly recommend you click here to
watch that video as well and then if
you're not subscribed to the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye
you